i think when it comes down for me i can
speak about
myself
i think everyone has their own choice
um to do what they feel is right for
themselves and their family things of
that nature
i know
that i was very skepticism about it all
but after doing my research and things
of that nature i felt like it was best
suited for not only people for my family
and my friends
and uh you know that's why i decided to
do it so but as far as
i don't
you guys should know me anything that i
talk about i don't talk about other
people and what they should do um i
speak for me um it's my family and uh
you know that's what it's about but you
don't think the issue is important
enough for someone with your stature to
speak out
you know we talk about individuals
bodies
you know we're not talking about
something that's you know political or
racism or police brutality and things of
that nature we talk about like people's
bodies and well beings you know so i
don't feel like for me personally and i
should get involved and what else people
should do for their bodies and their
livelihoods
or be
talking about somebody that they should
you know take this job or not listen you
have to do what's best for your family
they should relocate you have to do
what's best for your family so
i know what i did for you and my family
i know some of my friends and what they
do for their families but as far as
speaking for anybody their
individualities and things they want to
do um i don't feel like that's fine it's
not my job
all right